it's important to look at the background
to disinformation
or and other issues
because
this is playing a key role at the moment
first of all we have mr taras kuzio who
is professor of political science and
current
research fellow at the henry jackson
society in london then we have ms
ludmilia bitkumakuya i hope that i have
pronounced that correctly
associate professor at the national
university of kiev muller academy
and miss emilia kustova
representative of
memorial international the organization
pursued by the russian authorities and
associate professor of russian history
at the university of strasbourg
we will also hear from ms martinez
who is head of the east stratcom task
force at the eeas
we will also hear from her afterwards
but first of all mr kuzio you have the
floor for seven minutes
yes hello um i
i'm assuming you you can hear me um i am
going to really give the background to
understanding
why vladimir putin is obsessed with
ukraine why he launched an invasion of
ukraine that has led to this european
and global crisis
and i
placed the emphasis here on
the stagnation of nationalism in russia
during putin's presidency
back to what i would call the pre-soviet
understanding of the three eastern slavs
here i mean
that ukrainians russians and belarusians
are three branches of what was then used
to be called a pan-russian nation and
obscurus
so this is a
rejection of the soviet recognition of a
separate ukraine and a separate
ukrainian people this is going back to
um
late 19th early 20th century and what
was prevalent amongst white russian
emigrates
this is nothing new it's it's something
new for some reason amongst western
policy makers and western academics but
vladimir putin has been denying the
existence of ukraine and ukrainians
since at least 2008
and he has been making territorial
claims for
for the same period of time
and the um
link to this is is a is a perception
that the
the natural state of ukraine what
ukraine should look like in the eyes of
russian leaders is a country resembling
belarus under
under self-declared president alexander
lukashenko
so the
the goal of for example putin's goals of
demilitarization denuncification
are to transform
ukraine into a second belarus that is
the ultimate goal whether it's realistic
is a separate debatable question but
that's his goal
um and he really does and they really
did believe and
um for many many years in moscow
they have believed that
that the majority of ukrainians want to
be part of the russian world want to be
a part of the russian sphere of
influence but they have been denied that
right by
the
by nationalists who came to power in the
euro maidan revolution who have made
ukraine into a u.s puppet state
and that is an important way of
understanding
how
how moscow sees this crisis
it sees um
sees ukraine as a place that
has been unnaturally pulled away from
russia
most russians have always had difficulty
in in accepting an independent ukraine
this has been true for the last three
decades
and especially a ukraine which is
outside of the russian sphere of
influence i.e integrating into europe
nato eu
so what do they mean by
denatification densification means the
destruction of ukrainian national
identity which was cultivated during
three decades of nation building
so the transformation of ukraine into a
like a little russia
as a branch of that pan-russian nation
the installation the replacement of
voldemort zelensky with a pro-russian
puppet dictator
um similar to lukashenko
um
that would mean and the u.s intelligence
has leaked this many weeks ago a kill
list
uh ukrainian politicians
ukraine civil society activists
academics uh journalists who are who
support a pro-ukraine identity who
supported the euro maidan revolution who
support the pro-western orientation are
to be imprisoned
and potentially executed
and that those developments are already
happening and beginning in areas of
southern ukraine under russian
occupation
um putin's goal is to and he said this
on many occasions including
back to his famous essay in july of last
year
to
get rid of this anti-russia ukraine
that's how he sees it he sees the
nationalists and the united states eu of
having created this anti-russia in
ukraine and that has to be replaced by
this little russia
um
that could be also linked to potentially
dis dismembering ukraine with uh with
southern eastern ukraine be more closely
integrated into some thing that putin
revived in
2014 this so-called new russia
[Music]
vladimir putin and russian leaders have
said on many occasions that
soviet leaders were wrong to include
southern and eastern ukraine within the
ukrainian state
um
denatification once that is implemented
is supposed to then lead to
demilitarization which would be the
creation of this so-called neutral state
um which would no longer seek nato
membership but it's not just nato it
would be no longer seeking also eu
membership
because remember back in 2013-14
russia
applied intense pressure on
president yanukovych to reject the eu
ukraine association agreement and to
then turn ukraine eastwards towards
joining the eurasian economic union
putin wants to see
ukraine
kiev the so-called mother of russian
cities as part of the ruski mira the
russian world
and the russian world as the core
central three countries of the eurasian
economic union
and without ukraine that in in putin's
eyes that's wrong
putin sees himself
as this and he wants to see himself
going into russian history as the
gatherer of russian lands crimea
2014 belarus 2020 and ukraine now
so this
this entire
uh criminal invasion
is all linked to
um
a imperial nationalism that really is
completely out of place in a in a
post-modern uh european um
union
why why why did the invasion begin now
well i believe that um there are many
factors and i list them in one of these
slides
but in particular um
the russian
vladimir putin has been increasingly
isolated in the last few years he's
become increasingly obsessed with
ukraine reading this emigre and russian
nationalist literature you saw that in
his long essay published last year
um
president zielenski
um organized criminal charges of treason
against vladimir putin's representative
in ukraine viktor medve choke four
pro-russian television channels were
banned putin takes all of these actions
as very personal
um i think another another red line for
putin was the launch of the crimean
platform in august of last year to raise
international publicity about crimea
and then also in october ukraine began
using turkish made drones to
counter attack um when when there was
enemy fire on its positions in the
donbass so i think a combination of
those plus
i think in the kremlin in putin they
believed that
using the minsk agreements
and
um
small level high low cost low level
military pressure in the donbass had
failed
to achieve russia's goals and russia's
goals were always not compromised
but ukraine to capitulate and become
this second belurus so hence the arc the
artificial crisis began in november of
last year and it was a completely
artificial crisis because ukraine was
never going to be given the nato
membership at the time there was no us
missiles going to ukraine and ukraine
had been cooperating militarily with
nato for 30 years so nothing new had
happened except
in putin's
change and evolution this is a different
putin and more dictatorial putin
compared to 2014 and i think there's a
strong interconnection between
between domestic repression in russia
since the changing of the constitution
in 2020
and
the move towards a dictatorship in
russia and external aggression they're
closely connected between the two
vladimir putin has
completely miscalculated in this crisis
he's miscalculated in three ways
firstly with the russian people this is
not going to be a popular war in russia
this is not the same as in 2014 which
was popular i think your previous
speakers
are being a bit too liberal on this
question
unfortunately
support in russia for the occupation of
crimea has remained steady over the last
eight years at 85 percent support even
opposition leader alexei navalny
supports the occupation of crimea
so let's not
have illusions about this but
russia's invasion today will not
generate that same mobilization of
russian nationalism as the crimea
because the crimea is has a very special
link to russian national identity
so that's one thing
um in russia and of course the impact of
the western sanctions
is another miscalculation vladimir putin
expected russian leaders expected that
the west would be divided the west would
again
implement very weak sanctions as it did
in 2014. the sanctions in 2014 were well
i'm sorry to say quite pathetic
in response to what happened in ukraine
today they are not but they expected in
moscow
that that the sanctions would be again
weak and
there would be dissenters in europe
remember after 2008 in georgia there
were no sanctions 2014 there were weak
sanctions and now finally we have strong
sanctions so they miscalculated again
there
miscalculated in russian is calculated
in the west the third miscalculation was
inside ukraine because because of this
russian nationalist mythology that
ukrainians don't exist as a separate
people they believe that russian troops
will be seen as liberators
that they will be greeted with flowers
instead they were greeted with turkish
drones and western singers and javelins
and i think that the russian
there's a shock in the russian army at
the strength of the ukrainian anger and
resistance to this invasion they simply
never expected it to be like this and
you see that
on the ukrainian side there's high
morale high determination a lot of anger
on the russian side there isn't that
high morale
you see this in the dejection amongst
russian soldiers
putin has um
a major conundrum now and i'll i'll end
here
um
macho men like vladimir putin
are find it practically impossible to
retreat
how can they say they made a mistake
he's already blaming the the mistakes in
ukraine remember that they
expected that kiev and ukraine would be
occupied and captured within one to two
days
it's now third week
and the level of casualties of russian
soldiers is already higher than what the
u.s suffered over eight years in iraq
and over 20 years in afghanistan it's
it's practically
one practically 60 percent of soviet
casualties in afghanistan after eight
years
so this is very very bad and a lot of
also equipment lost so putin's putin's
conundrum things are not going well can
he retreat metro men don't retreat can
he go forward
that's also problematical
um because kiev is not aleppo or
grozny
aleppo and grozny were less than one
million populations kiev is four million
so it's a much bigger city to capture
far more problematical there'll be
resistance will be very high and russian
troops would suffer tremendous losses
yes of course there would be probably a
lot of destruction of ukiv from this
but
how would this respond back in russia
how would it look in russia that the
russian leader is destroying the
so-called mother of russian cities the
the city that's supposed to be where
the three eastern slavs were created in
kievrus and if putin is seen as
destroying that i think that will
undermine his legitimacy
so he has a major conundrum what to do
um that because um that and this is why
there doesn't seem to be much real
a strategy as to where russia is going
in this conflict except
except by
un unveiling massive destruction on on
buildings and on
on the civilian population
so i will um
i think ended on ended on this question
um
uh the the driving factor in all of this
war is putin's personal obsession
with taking back what he sees as little
russia ukraine
um and because of that
um we have this tremendous tragedy
unfolding in in ukraine and this
tremendous tragedy in europe and the
world thank you very much
thank you very much and now our next
speaker will be ludmilia pitque muy
please you have the floor
is she connected
mrs pikunmika you can press and speak
button at the bottom of your page now
your connection is open
thank you
please can you press the speak button
yes i press it can you hear me
i press the stick button
can hear you it's fine we can hear you
and we can see
thank you
uh good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
i'm delighted to be here today to
outline the mean
historical myth in the kremlin
propaganda as well as to characterize
the main channels and platforms
through which this means have been
spread
in addition i will indicate how
manipulation of history has become one
of the instruments for russia's
intervention in ukraine and served as a
pretext for the current war
um in the address to the russians after
the russian security council meeting on
the february 21st
vladimir putin described his version of
the history of ukraine
according to his words ukraine
was a literally created by lenin who
gave it
too much autonomy in the soviet state by
saying that ukraine had not existed
before putin declared that it was purely
russian territory thus he tried to lay
the foundations for possible large-scale
attack which began on the 24th
of february
many russians see ukraine as a
litter brother little russian as
professor koza has already mentioned who
must obey the elder
or it will be forced to do so in the
meantime russia has proclaimed itself a
world power a next slide please
the ideology of uniqueness of the
russian civilization is reflected in the
national security strategy from the 2nd
of july last year and information and
psychologists sabotaged and
westernization of culture by the russian
federation of its cultural sovereignty
attempts to falsify russian award
history distort the historical truth
and
uh destroy historical memory inside
inter-ethnic and interfaith conflicts
weaken the state forming people have
become more frequent the next slide
plays
in vladimir putin's uh article on the
history unity of russians and ukrainians
that has been already mentioned
today from the 12th of july the history
of russian ukrainian relations is
dominated by the claim that ukrainians
are an asian inseparable part of the
triune russian
nation
according to the kremlin narrative this
community is based on a common history
spanning 1 000 years the language the
russian ethnic identity the shared
cultural sphere and the orthodox
religion the next slide please
in this presentation i have
distinguished three main manipulative
techniques or myth uh in the kremlin
narration that uh ukraine or ukraine uh
stands for okraina outskirt uh actually
i i don't want to pay so much attention
because this theory have been already um
disproved uh by ukrainian as well as by
european linguist the second
manipulation is about similarities and
common language for all slavic peoples
um alexis shakhmat of theory of the
origin of islamic languages according to
which all islamic peoples russians
ukrainians and belarusians and their
languages originated from all russian
unity and all russian proto-language
became known at the basis
of russian
imperial policy soviet policy and
actually the current
putin's policy
this theory has been uh also already
disproved by american and ukrainian
linguists
so we can come to the next point which
is the imperial interpretation of key
one uh ruth
at the cradle of three fraternal peoples
russian ukrainian and belarusian which
remains a canonical historical scheme in
the russian federation
this mean had been actively used not
only in the aforementioned
article
by vladimir putin but also in his early
speeches i assume since 2008 russian
orthodox church media education etc
soviet myth of russian ukrainian
so-called fraternal brotherhood that
deny ukrainian right to independence and
depict russians and ukrainians as one
people adinarot
are pervasive in the putin's article as
well as all kremlin uh propaganda
after the russian federation started its
full-scale war in ukraine the kremlin
decided to just to justify its actions
by resorting to well-known theses
and
manipulations in the frame of all
russian open lesson defenders of peace
for school children that was held on the
3rd of march
this year and actually during this
lesson the teachers spoke about the
so-called liberation mission in ukraine
and why it was necessary in order to
impose a strong impact on the youngest
groups of population russia used the
narratives you were able to see on that
slide the next slide place
another channel for spreading the
government's narratives and historical
myth to influence not only pupils but
also other strata
of society
is from link
media that have been and remain the most
powerful tool for russian propaganda
the idea of the ukrainian and russian
likeness is a major component uh for
instance in the
analyzed
program
nada pagari we need to talk and is
realized at the level of world
combinations such as ukrainians alike
russians the fraternal people we think
alike one nation common families movies
holidays we are all one etc in the
aforementioned program guest and
guest and the host were discussing love
friendship relationships whatever but
did not resort to policies politics and
to the analysis of the causes that led
to the russian ukrainian war
this is uh in line with the concept of
the kremlin propaganda and kremlin
manipulation techniques that the viewer
is given a ready-made and clear idea
rather than a possibility to think
analyze for themselves what indeed is
unfolding around them the next slide
please
in addition to the media mass culture
also plays an important role in
establishing russia as a superpower and
a successor of kievan ruiz
the image of prince willowdimer called
also valodimer the great who baptized
the ruse has been actively used recently
in the cartoons fiction films
documentaries and even games some of the
examples you are able to see on this
slide voldemort the great was recalled
by putin at the powerful gesture of a
timeless superhero
who predetermines the oral basis of the
cultural civilization and human values
that unite the peoples of russia ukraine
and belarus at the end of the quote and
actually
there's nothing to say that such
concepts as russia ukraine and belarus
uh did not exist at that time
it is uh worth mentioning the russian
federation has been actively
constructing monuments to voldemort
great in the in recent 10 years and
actually currently there are twice as
many monuments in russia than uh in
ukraine uh as far as i am concerned and
as far as counted
15 against
eight
the next slide please
and actually the final one uh timothy
snyder emphasized that the story by
putin's article reveals how ill russia
is in the development of its own uh
national story
the way that mr putin tells his story
ukraine is a a kind of crutch belarus is
a kind of crutch russia is unable to
tell its story about itself so the story
he told relies upon other peoples thus
the russian propaganda machine like its
soviet predecessor is falsifying
historical facts and distorting data in
order to demonstrate ukraine's
inferiority minimize its culture and
distort its language these narratives
are spread through various platforms and
channels as you have noticed education
mass media and mass culture as a result
of the kremlin propaganda ukraine is not
capable of banking on an independent
future and separate development i would
just like to finish with the words of
raymond miliganite i hope i pronounced
correctly her name information and
communication officer of the east
stratcom
who said for the kremlin history is not
something to be studied and remembered
but something to be managed to justify
russia's current actions thank you for
your attention
thank you very much
for this insight you gave us and now
i passed the floor to emilia kustova
representative of the russian
organization memorial international
and
at the moment professor at the
university of strasbourg
you remember memorial is also one of the
organize is one organization who got the
uh sacharov prize of the european
parliament
so please
mrs kustova you have the floor please
press speak button
[Music]
thank you very much for this
invitation
just wanted uh to check that you can
hear me
with the russian invasion of ukraine the
uh world is discovering the place that
history occupies in the official russian
narrative and the
extent of its distortion
these speeches about
history have been
been constructed over the last few years
uh really over 10 years
the arrival of putin to power in 2000
was already accompanied by
some
signs announcing of the instrumental
instrumentalization of history
and this
would be the content of future
russian's
novels and
russia
putin insisted on the role of history in
uh teaching
and uh
he promoted uh at the center of his uh
narrative references to the uh major
patriarchic
war which is what they call the second
world war still in russia
but
for them it started in 1941 rather than
1939.
so
there were uh people uh talking about
this uh
and there was a a fight against the
falsification of history in 2009 but uh
the uh
room for maneuver for civil society was
still quite broad uh during the first
decade of putin so rule after that uh
the regime have become tougher and
laws restricting uh freedoms were
adopted in 2011 2012
and the
distortion of history became explicit
putin
often spoke about russia's pastor and
its place in society and contemporary
society
he declared for example at the beginning
of 2013
that the main resource of power
and the future of russia resides in our
historical memory so history becomes a
resource just like oil
and this desire
to
put history at the surface of patriotic
education and legitimizing a
governmental policy in so doing uh has
led to the deployment of a whole range
of tools
to
spread the russian narrative and to
limit the scope of dissenting voices
particularly the voices of memorial
and
this served to construct the patriotic
narrative
commemorations
school books
monuments
museums
traditional things and others are more
innovative for example the creation in
2012 are two institutions presented as
being autonomous uh
although they are not
uh uh independent uh the russian history
uh society and the russian military
history society both of them uh come and
uh
strong men of the regime nashkin on the
one hand and vladimir nizinski on the
other hand and these institutions play a
key role in the instrumentalization of a
history in russia
other tools are used for example
exhibitions which
first show in moscow and then are
reproduced elsewhere all this uh
serves to
introduce a narrative a vision of a
military state uh
power which uh goes back
thousands of years back to the uh russia
of kiev
and
at the center of this so what they value
is everything which makes the russian
state strong
and powerful both within the country and
on the international stage
this narrative also condemns any popular
movement which may contest it of course
the
major patriotic war
uh uh occupies an essential place it
already had its place during of the
soviet era but it was
weakened a bit during perestroika and
the 90s
so the idea is to construct an uh
building
an edifice of identity
so
this
is why stalin is often rehabilitated not
systematically
until recently at least
and
this is why violence of stalin's policy
is often attenuated and
in the victory in 1945
is seen as a new beginning uh with the
reestablishment of the imperial
territory with some exceptions and
new legitimacy paid in blood
and the idea is to save a welder from
fascism and the russian nature has
therefore
gained a place amongst the greater it is
now definitively uh in the camper of the
forces of good which makes it uh
unacceptable to reevaluate its role
during the conflict in any
dispute of current policies uh is dealt
with likewise so this crucial role in
the war is used to justify the first
attack against ukraine in 2014 and it's
happening again
now so it's so
the main crimes against history are also
linked to the ukrainian war
uh that's uh was in the report of the uh
which was published in 2021
of the fidh
and of course we uh this led to the
liquidation of memorial there are
certain typologies of measures against
freedom uh for example
the collection of information
making it more difficult to gain access
to the archive sir
and also spreading knowledge with
censorship and criminalization of
certain narratives
there's also a part of the general legal
framework which has become increasingly
oppressive since
2012
and also others what
is linked to the history of memorial
itself for example the law and foreign
agents adopted in 2012 which made it
much more difficult for ngos to function
including memorial
which finally led to uh the
uh splitting up
uh the closure of that energy
all these are tools uh are obstacles
therefore for the activities of memorial
and other independent stakeholders in
the historical demand apart from these
general tools which restrict a freedom
others have been used on an ad hoc way
to do away with any narrative which does
not conform to the official one in 2014
of course first attack against ukraine
it was crucial because it was then
the law was adopted
although
it was dormant for several years before
that
criminalizing the rehabilitation of
nazism and it uses uh
very vague notions which allows
you to
punish with up to 50 years imprisonment
of anything which moves away from the
official narrative and which can be
designated as spreading
information which is knowingly false on
the activities of the soviet union
during the second world war so you can
understand that with a war like this
this is no longer possible to truly
study the history of the second world
war and in 2020
amendments to the constitution were made
which were already mentioned by
professor cortio
these amendments
uh postulate that uh
the mission of the russian federation is
to protect historical truth and one of
the amendments uh
does not allow
minimalizing the heroism of the people
under the game we think of the second
world war and the toolbox was completed
in 2020 and it was therefore ready to be
mobilized to impose a single vision of
history crushing any alternatives
and any desire
to
adopt a professional humanist view on
universal russian history as has always
been done
by memorial and i hope maria will
continue to do so thank you
thank you
for your uh lecture and uh
before i open the questions we also i
have a mrs martinez bill to you kievitch
please try and stick to five minutes so
people still have the possibility of
asking a questions and then we can take
some answers as well
good afternoon everyone
can you hear me
we can hear you and we can see you
perfectly
fantastic thank you very much i will try
to be brief especially given that
many very important points
were raised already so maybe just an
additional perspective from uh strategy
communications
uh task force we deal with uh program
and russia's disinformation since 2015
and what we see and actually my
colleague raymond miglinita was quoted
already
we see that the kremlin has been trying
to manage history for years
um the political leadership in russia
uses history as a political instrument
to foster legitimacy at home and to
frame russia's international role
and historic revisionism is integrated
into russia's domestic and foreign
policy
domestically the goal is mostly to
consolidate the nation under the banner
of patriotism um against an external
enemy and here i'm going to use uh um
quite often one word that is very
disturbing for us europeans and this is
the word nazi this has been a prevalent
narrative
very
aggressively pushed by the kremlin
for a few years
but especially right now i will come
back to this
internationally
russia aims to create an image of itself
as a sole force of resistance against
nazism both now and throughout history
so anyone questioning the role of the
ussr for example in world war ii and its
aftermath is a target of disinformation
attacks coming both from the media loyal
to the kremlin and from the official
sources
that's by the way included european
parliament
a few years ago when the resolution on
the importance of european remembrance
for the future of europe was adopted
back in 2019.
we have seen similar narratives put by
the kremlin and its media for years i've
said that already
examples would include the case of the
illegal annexation in crimea in 2014
under the pretext of a neo-nazi coup
which is how pro kremlin outlet and the
kremlin administration uh
portrays maiden it's how how they call
the maidan revolution
and those efforts intensified in 2019
and 2020 in line with relevant
narratives of world war ii as well as
preparation for constitutional changes
and presidential elections
in russia
and again those narratives appeared in
the build-up to the war especially in
the last few months
um more specifically when we take a look
at the last three months before putin
attacks ukraine again
we can see that throughout the ecosystem
of the kremlin's media the number of
mentions of the word nazi grew by 290
percent
this clearly clearly shows where this
informational machine wanted to go to
justify the war to make us and
especially the russian audience believe
that nazis rule ukraine and
therefore need to be toppled
this
made-up narrative continues also
throughout the war and
the most gruesome example of last days
is russia's attack on the maternity ward
in mario paul
which was explained
quotation marks here by russian
authorities and their media as the need
to clear the area from neo-nazis nazis
so basically they lie to our faces and
they use those lies to justify violence
and murder
my team is stratcom task force which is
part of the european external action
service has been consistently monitoring
and analyzing programming campaigns
including those campaigns of historical
revisionism
in our publicly available database of
disinformation cases
which we are
working on since 2015 we collect a few
hundreds of examples of this information
related to historical revisionism
um and we regularly publish products to
raise awareness about the kremlin's
attempt
of historical revisionism
now i can go into details if there are
questions
or if there's any need for me to go into
details we also share regularly with eu
institutions and member states our
findings and most importantly we
try as much as we can to raise awareness
about this issue because historical
revisionism and lies about history are
an inherent part of russia's
disinformation campaigns and we see them
very much reflected in the current war
again i will stop right there thank you
very much
thank you very much
i think it was very important for us to
hear all of these presentations to get a
general view
of uh how
history can be manipulated
and how a manipulating narrative can be
used as a justification for war and
abuse of
human rights so i think we've seen this
in the past
we we uh have to ensure that we don't
just see one narrative but we have to
address uh history from different angles
and in a critical way
so now i would like to give
the floor to our political groups
thomas vankowski two minutes please
stick to the time because we don't have
much time left
thank you and i'd like to thank all the
experts for having made their
presentations
it seems that um putin is trying to
carve out his place in
history by returning russia to its right
status as professor kusio said
ukraine is only the beginning of
this historical revisionism crusade and
is he going to go further towards
moldavia and
moldova or
georgia and what can the european
institutions do to thought this
propaganda
i also would like to ask mrs ludmila you
said that to a great extent this
propaganda begins at school
obviously this is um
uh present in the media and in maths
culture popular culture what are the
chances of
accessing
independent sources
and what are the chances of reducing the
impact of russian
propaganda yesterday we heard we saw the
brave journalist who rushed on to the
stage with
uh with a placard saying that this was
all fake and um against the war
and what what kind of impact will this
have on the consciousness of russians
and i would like to ask all
experts about the possible scenarios for
the future
do you expect russians to begin to
see what's going on or will they go more
towards this patriots patriotism which
was we just heard about
him
thank you very much
thank you
for these very informative
contributions i think they've
illustrated that the narrative which is
at the uh
root of this war has started beforehand
but clearly this is a picture of history
and a picture of human beings
which has no place in modern times uh
it's not about
peace uh welfare quality of life
democracy
peaceful living together it's about a
territory expansion and it's a
an interruption of history and the eu is
an answer to this uh if
i uh
go uh everywhere in europe i i
can come across uh
um
lots of uh battlegrounds which achieved
nothing apart from many deaths um uh we
uh of course we've got
videos and tv being used to spread the
narrative and we have to
counter that
and despite our
good political
education and academic education there
are lots of stereotypes
around and even the best education can
often not overcome these stereotypes and
these stereotypes are arising from the
war
and as has been said already i think
it's important
uh to include the uh russian speakers in
our countries and inform them uh
that uh
so that they can get uh
a different picture to this official
narrative
so my questions uh refer to one aspect
which hasn't yet been mentioned or only
briefly which is religion
putin is tried to use orthodoxy in other
member states of the eu to to influence
those countries uh and uh on the soviet
uh view of history uh what about the
hitler style impact is that a a topic
being used at the moment
and also how
much in danger are the baltic countries
plus finland and another attack
issue is that the term nazis has been
used on many occasions in the russian
federation is there any
uh anti-semitic group or groups or are
there far right organizations which use
violence and also this
picture of
neo-nazis in ukraine are there any
reasons
to
suspect that that was the case uh in a
recent ukrainian history thank you very
much it is important for us to
take a look at our own history
thank you uh renew bernard getter
id
nobody has asked for the floor has
anybody connected from id who would like
to speak on behalf of
that group apparently not
greens same applies
nobody
would anybody like to speak on behalf of
the greens
no
andre eslavakov ecr
mr zlavakov in order to take the floor
you need to activate your camera and
your microphone
if you can hear me to do that you need
to go on the upper left corner where you
see the gear settings icon
yes now you should be able to take the
floor
mr slavakov please press the speak
button
thank you chair
i'm afraid the speaker is just
impossible to
hear
why is
now if we are to fight the propaganda
and what comes from russia
we are ready to create propaganda on our
own
do not forget that in any conflict there
are two sides
ukraine and russia does not delude
ourselves are very close and this is not
only due to geography
three countries there
belarus
ukraine and russia are looking for
kiev rus
for
their historic roots
i am against all types of wars and i
think that this is disgusting because
the people who suffer the most are the
citizens the
civilians
they are the people who die the
propaganda on behalf of russia
manipulates history in order to achieve
political aims
and to find a reasonable explanation for
such an invasion i don't believe that we
should also
uh turn what is going on into some into
a narrative
we know that ukraine would like to join
the western world they would like to
separate themselves from the former
ussr they want to have a
future in the western european
area but at the same time they should
not
denote their past
i will finish with the words of an
italian journalist
if i heard rightly foiaci
and that i will switch to italian
what happens in the world oh it can be
seen from three points of view mine
yours
and the truth
connections are
broken unfortunately so i'll give the
floor to mr getter
sorry about this
confusion just now
but let me try and underscore an
important point
so all these
analyses
of historical revolutionism
should
not
allow us to believe
that
these activities
um
concern only
don't concern the majority only a
minority
not even a strong minority
let's just have a look at a few points
why is it that mr putin has
banned the word war
it's illegal to say the word war i mean
it's a bit odd isn't it
i mean he said look there was a drugged
nazi in power in the kf
so it's not
illegitimate to launch a war against a
drug addict
nazi who happens to be in power in
uh in kiev now if he
doesn't introduce the word war
it is because this word
is
extremely unpopular in russia today and
then the other thing
a couple of days ago
can't remember exactly when it was
you'll excuse me for this
i think it was
on the 8th of march on international
women's day why was it then that he said
that
conscripts will not be sent to the front
uh to this war which is not actually a
war in the ukraine
well first of all it was a lie
we know perfectly well that a huge
number of conscript
were sent out to this front and why did
he take this precaution
why because he's afraid
and quite rightly so
he's quite
worried
about
the same thing happening now as what
happened in afghanistan
when young conscripts were coming back
from afghanistan in body bags
mr putin is perfectly aware of the fact
well to be polite
how can i put it well perhaps i won't be
polite is he's perfectly well of the
fact that the
rubbish which he's
spewing on ukraine and on russia and on
the history of these two countries the
utter garbage
is not
widely shared in russia at all
as just in the same way as what what mr
zemo in france utters is not
particularly
agreed with in that country
and
let's be
let's be aware of all of this and
i would like to express my thanks to the
chair for having and
having organized this debate and
this exchange of views and have an idea
about what is going on in the brain of
the person
who is ruling russia at the moment but
let's not say it's the fault of the
russians themselves
thank you very much
the next speaker
is milan
thank you very much
thank you for giving me the floor
madame chair thank you very much to all
of the speakers for their presentations
here
in the culture committee i never thought
we would speak about war but today we
are witnesses to such a discussion and
this is right
it's right to discuss this madam chair
i'd like to briefly inform you that
three
prime ministers are traveling to kiev
today czech republic poland and slovenia
this is a very courageous act
we hope
that the objective of that mission will
be achieved
i would like
to
ask the professor
do you think that the west has reacted
properly and correctly to putin's
threats over the past 14 years
i
don't believe they have i think that the
intelligence services have analyzed
things incorrectly and politicians
haven't listened
and thank you very much mr sphere the
left didn't uh
register a speaker so i didn't uh see mr
mersey and then dominic much
first of all i will i would like to make
a remark
all this analysis about
nationalism
historical memory
history teaching
as a tool in the hands of nation's
elites
is very common for every single nation
state
there's nothing unique
in russia about that we experience this
in different parts of the world and
still we experiencing it today very
rightly we see with reference to eric
zemol
how much
his discord has in common
with
uh the score of uh putin or i could say
turkish president erdogan or others
so
and again i go back to we found founders
of the eu that the new nationalism means
war
and either we defeat nationalism or we
are defeated by nationalism so this is
first thing to say now i have some
questions short questions first one goes
about
um
about certain um
um
ivan ilin
whose grave was transported to russia by
putin 2005
from abroad and he was a well-known
christian fascist adoring hitler
and i found out that actually putin is
referring to his writings from time to
time
uh i wanted to know is really illin a
kind of philosopher in france in putin
and putin's ideological formation
my second question is about the
anti-western dimension of russian
racialism nationalism i think that goes
back in history how strong is
anti-western emotions
in in in russia
and my third question would be about the
russian minority in ukrainian
how much rare rights are protected
democratically in ukraine or not is
there unsolved issues such as language
or cultural identities
is ukraine a multicultural democracy or
needs to be one
thank you
thank you very much dominic
thank you madam chairman and i'd like to
thank all the experts who've already
spoken
and as uh bernard my friend and
colleague said i'm delighted that this
meeting is being held because historical
revisionism
is in some ways
a cultural
diversion it's another weapon in the uh
war chest of president putin i would
like to
avail myself of the presence of our
guests to talk about two possible
initiatives uh that we could take on our
side given that as we have heard
there is official history uh which is
the only version permitted a very biased
version as we've seen in russia so how
can the eu
help to develop
together with organizations such as
memorial
how can we support uh
european and russian history
uh with academics and people from
russian civil society
the project that the french presidency
proposed
uh the commission on european history
that could be a space for dialogue and
uh collaboration and we could also
suggest
you and i are in
on the board of the european house
perhaps uh the european house of history
could also
uh
address the topic of historical
revisionism given the current
circumstances
thank you very much
i think
in this house
on several occasions we have discussed
how to deal with
teaching history even in european states
and nice
and i think that
in the committee we had a dispute with
the polish ministry for education
and this was
about history
being taught from
one perspective
europe is built
on
a consensus on presenting
different points of view
different perspectives on history
obviously the
perspective of
the victor of a war is different from
the
country that loses the war or the
countries that were attacked have
different perspective than the attackers
but
now
you could say that rome could attack us
because previously everything was roman
or
charlemagne
could
uh have for example germany and france
together now this is obviously or very
arbitrary because we have international
treaties international agreements and
this is what should count
what should count is what is we have
agreed upon not about what has happened
what happened hundreds of hundreds of
years ago
so
history has been so varied in europe
and
often the continent
reacted more unified in the past than we
have done in recent history so all
sides of history need to be taught we
need to also understand the perspective
of how
for example how
history teaching is manipulated
and
certain narratives are used to spread
political propaganda or in this case
to actually pursue a war
and i think it's very important to look
at that
i'd like to thank
all of our speakers and experts today
for their presentations i think it
really helped us all
to learn about
the background to the situation
and
now in reverse order
because perhaps we
we won't have uh
interpretation very soon and we'll need
to continue working in english
would somebody else like to take the
floor if i miss somebody
okay now then first of all i'd like to
give the floor to ms kustova
and then
i'll give the floor
excuse me miss pid cui muka
and then mr cruz here so miss kuster
where you have the floor
merci
hello um
thank you
so i'll reply to some of the questions
or remarks which have been made
certainly not all of them
i think
all of these
questions are extremely interesting and
obviously very complex too especially
regarding all the possible scenarios
but
specifically
[Music]
etc
foreign
[Music]
in
foreign
difficulty
russia
um
[Music]
um
merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup the next is ludmilia
pitmo
sorry ludmila pitcui muka
can you hear me now
yes we can
i just wanted to say that you really
pronounce great my last name usually
people make really many mistakes in that
um
answering the question how views
is able uh to get information and like
not uh
kremlin propaganda information actually
nowadays uh we can see that a bit
difficult because as far as you probably
know that facebook twitter instagram
uh that are very very popular among
young people uh are forbidden in russia
and people have no excess
so even a criminal liability for
spreading so-called fakes against
russian army or saying truth
about the war in ukraine
is announced in russia so nowadays it's
a bit tough for
school children for use to get ins to
get information because most of them is
getting that information from uh social
uh media
speaking about uh religion
and how important uh it is uh for russia
i guess professor kouzou would answer
more in details because he is dealing
with that topic more than me but i have
mentioned that
actually
um
this like increasing of monuments to
volodymyrs the great who baptized uh the
rules and like also this myth about uh
unite orthodox church and for all three
peoples ukrainian and russians is also a
kind
of myth uh in
current russian
uh
manipulation machine
um
[Music]
also briefly answering like uh to andre
slabaco um
question why uh ukrainians the like uh
wanna
go european way yes we said yes to uh
european way in 2013 when the revolution
of dignity or euromaidan started uh and
why we don't didn't uh value our history
i just wanna say that uh we do not
refuse our past uh we are proud of our
past uh we just don't wanna russia steal
our history and steal our past and use
it uh like against it while preparing
this presentation i read also
an article by bernard andre levy french
philosopher writer publicist
who wrote let me quote
ukraine
putin says has a common history with
russia but this is the story of
colonization under bolsheviks anarchists
from odessa were swept away with an iron
boom and then there was stalin the
holodomor which killed around 6 million
people so
if if you are talking about common
history with russia that is our common
history with russia
also i would like briefly uh say about
um
state and status of russian national
minority
in ukraine unfortunately there was no
synthesis since 2001
and i can't say for sure how many ethnic
russians live in ukraine but i can say
for sure that
very many people speak russian they are
not ethnic russians they just speak
russian because of uh bolshevik uh
language policy and soviet uh language
policy because of russification and um i
was dealing a bit with like russian um
media in uh ukraine uh so i just
briefly uh in 2019 unfortunately i don't
have like right now um an appropriate uh
statistics but in 2019 there were more
than 300 papers published
in russian and the
number of copies of to be perfectly
honest
there were more ukrainian papers
but
the number of copies
of ukraine of russian um papers and
magazines uh was higher than uh even
ukrainian and also in 2016
um it was um
the survey rusev identity in ukraine in
the context of the armed conflict in the
east of the country and there were like
focus groups with people from russian
speaking regions of ukraine harki of her
son and kiev actually those regions who
regions who are mostly bombed uh right
now and people noted that they are not
discriminated against on the grounds of
language and therefore there is no need
to preserve or protect
the russian
language
and speaking also about the law on
education and about the
language law
i wanted to say that um
actually
this laws no way for beats using russian
hungarian romanian or other languages
but requires ukrainian citizens to know
ukrainian and actually these laws are
aimed at protecting minorities and
integrate their representatives into
ukrainian society
and on the other hand to protect
and
unite ukraine and i would uh
like to say that political social
education and cultural rights of the
national minorities in ukraine are
respected unfortunately there is not so
much time to go in details but there are
two articles i have already published on
that question and i i they are available
in internet thank you so much thank you
very much for these clear words
and now tarascusio
mr cozier please can you press the speak
button
it's pressed okay
um i think that is that okay
fine we can hear you and we can see yeah
okay i think that there are
many good-hearted liberal but quite
naive people um listening to this um
regarding attitudes inside russia
i've already mentioned that in the last
eight years there's been an steady
85 support for russia's annexation of
crimea and it would be it would be
ridiculous to assume there's no
connection between what happened in 2014
and what happened now in 2014 vladimir
putin raised the
and he described southeastern ukraine in
saras terms as new russia
he didn't then invade and occupy the
region now he's doing that so there's a
direct connection between the two i
think russians people should understand
that secondly
there is one independent sociological
service in russia called the levada
center i
cite them all the time and they have
found majorities of russians supporting
the separation of occupied donbass from
ukraine only 20 percent of russians
believe it should remain inside ukraine
this is before the invasion
a majority of russians also support
issuing passports to
ukrainians living in those occupied
areas of donbass
and also um majority of russians
support the
um so-called uh volunteers if really
nationalist mercenaries traveling to the
region to fight ukrainian government
forces so we have to be very careful yes
it's true
that the invasion is never going to be
as popular as what happened in 2014 with
crimea
um and even people who support the
annexation of crimea like alexey navalny
who does support this and alex say
navalny also believes ukraines and
russians are one people
um but i don't believe that navalny if
he was president would invade ukraine so
you can be a supporter but not
necessarily do what putin's done
i think that
where this is going to have an impact
inside russia is the huge number of
casualties coming back what is really
unpleasant about the war taking place is
that russian authorities don't care
about their casualties they they don't
try to collect the dead bodies of
russian soldiers so they are simply left
where they have been killed um
on the ukraine side that's completely
different
i think also
when more information comes into russia
about casualties about what russian army
is doing destroying
property and destroying ukrainian
infrastructure that will have an impact
back home
and
even though there is control of media it
is impossible to block this information
from completely going back to russia
just like in the 1980s it was impossible
for the soviet union to block
information coming back about soviet
casualties
on the question of uh russian immigrant
authors like ivan ilyan ivan ilyam was a
was a an anti-semitic fascist
white emigrate just like many of the
white russian emigrates
but the most important thing
on the question of this debate is that
um ilyan and many similar
uh white russian immigrant writers
denied the existence of ukraine and
below russians and they believed in the
tsarist view which putin also believes
that there is a pan-russian nation
obscurus narod composed of three
eastern slavic peoples so the coming
back the bringing back of and the
re-burial of white russian emigre
writers and and military leaders and the
republishing of their works
obviously has had a major impact inside
the russian leadership vladimir putin
from 2005 onwards recommends that
political leaders governors regional
governors all read evan ilyan and um who
is this fascist and an anti-anti-semite
on the question of xenophobia yes of
course
um
there has been a strong level of
anti-western xenophobia um in the
russian leadership since vladimir
putin's famous speech at the munich
security conference in february 2007
and and the war in ukraine in the eyes
of putin and the kremlin is a proxy war
against the west
as i've already mentioned um they
believe that ukraine is a u.s puppet
state um and which was and that the the
euro madame revolution was a was a
so-called illegal push organized by the
european union cia et cetera
um and so they believe that they are
fighting the west in ukraine they're not
just fighting ukrainian nationalists
they're fighting ukraine nationalists
and the western ukraine and as a goal
towards
changing the so-called unipolar world to
a multi-polar world
and changing the european security
architecture on the question of uh the
russian minority we have to be careful
here
because it's a very small minority
ukraine is the fourth
most nationally homogeneous country in
europe despite all the stereotypes about
ukraine being regionally divided ukraine
has
92 percent of the population declare
themselves to be ethnic ukrainian
um and one one reason here is that many
of the
mixed families um which existed in the
soviet union in 1991 um where you had
ukrainian russian mixed families many of
them have now
evolved into becoming ukrainian it's now
more popular to be ukrainian amongst
young people it's practically not 92 is
96
um the number of people in ukraine who
are declaring themselves to be ethnic
russian has declined from the soviet
census of 1989 when it was 22 percent to
the ukrainian census in 2001 when it was
17 and now it's about six percent and of
course the more there is russian
military aggression against ukraine the
more that uh there will be this self
re-identification
one final thing on russian speakers uh
population
um
the uh russian-speaking ukrainians are
patriots of ukraine this was true in
nineteen in 2014
when putin's new new russia project
failed and uh russian speakers in the
south and east supported ukraine not
putin
not putin's policies
but of course in moscow
they simply are
unable to understand the very concept of
russian-speaking ukrainian patriotism
for them
ruski is actually a russian speaker
means
that they should be pro putin
pro-russian world and want to be part of
that sphere of influence they cannot
understand that no um there is a civic
identity and voldemort zelensky is the
example of that
he is from the region of nipper petrovsk
which is adjacent to the west of the the
donbass conflict zone he's a russian
speaker
and he's of jewish background
and the majority in every region of
ukraine voted for him in april 2019
except one
um so
um
ukraine has
civic nationalism patriotism not ethnic
nationalism in fact i would say in
ukraine elections uh ukraine has the
lowest support for extreme right parties
probably anywhere in europe um they they
never get any any any votes um and
and and i think on that i i will i will
leave it thank you very much
thank you very much uh and i also even
they are not there anymore want to say
thank you to the interpreters who
uh
spend us ten extra minutes
but
now i'm i'm quite happy that many of you
still stayed here even we did not have
interpretation anymore but i think it
was important to listen
and it was a good input we could get
thank you very much for that to all uh
the speakers we had this afternoon i
think it was an enlightening and very
interesting
exchange of views we had this afternoon
and
i hope you agree that it was worth it to
stay half an hour longer than normally
planned thank you very much and now i
leave you to the evening instead of
those who are coordinators because they
have to start
nearly immediately with the coordinators
meeting i want just to remind you that
on the 25th of april we will have our
next meeting here in brussels thank you
very much and
i just interrupt for a few minutes and
then we can start with the coordinators
meeting thanks
you